in city after city the left's draconian
pandemic restrictions
they are now coming back vaccine
mandates are creeping into public policy
including new requirements for new york
city workers
and va employees and now masked mandates
in
la st louis uh savannah georgia many of
the liberal cities
are they're now bringing these mandates
back and that's not all
two months ago it was joe biden who
proudly declared
a policy of vax or mask well now the cdc
is
considering a revised new new new new
policy
of that vax and mask now how many more
mixed messages
will the american people be given no
mask
one mast two masks no mask
some mass mask indoors mask outdoors and
maybe mass
in perpetuity uh and now it's oh never
mind what we said before
and remember according to democrats the
media mob and the
great flip flop dr anthony fauci well
life was supposed to return to normal
for vaccinated americans that's what
they told us
you might remember take a look so if we
can get
the overwhelming proportion of the
population vaccinated
by let's say the end of the second the
beginning of the third quarter
by the time we get into mid-fall of 2021
we could be approaching some level of
normality
what does 70 percent mean it means that
we can now
return to life as we know it
the biggest takeaway is that getting
vaccinated is our ticket
back to normal we need of course to keep
up the effort to inoculate the rest of
the country
but suffice it to say we are well on our
way to bringing the country
out of chaos out of crisis and back
to normal the vaccines are about
saving your life but also the lives of
the people around you
but they're also about helping to get us
get back to closer to normal in our
living
more normal living and that and that was
just a few weeks ago now we're just
supposed to accept another
new normal the 100th new normal with
masks and social distancing
and lockdowns even if you're vaccinated
indefinitely
again even if you're fully vaccinated
how is this
following the science that they lectured
us every day that was supposed to follow
are we supposed to ignore the science
for example from the cleveland clinic
very well respected medical institution
that if you had covet you don't need any
vaccine
oh spoiler alert the mask obsessed left
in america is not
following the science and they're trying
to blame conservatives for
vaccine hesitancy when it's they
themselves that are causing a lot of it
they're panicking they're flailing
flipping and flopping daily
now this might be a surprise for anyone
in the media mob who is
tuning in for the first time but well
i've been saying
for months and months and months over
and over and over again
yeah you better take this virus
seriously yes it's deadly
we can read the numbers and it can kill
you i do believe in science
i believe in the science of vaccination
but i'm not your doctor
i'm not going to give you or anybody
medical advice
and frankly like many americans i'm fed
up with the ever-changing policies and
advice
they can't see it's like the gang that
can't shoot straight
so yeah take this seriously do your own
extensive
research talk to actual medical
professionals you trust
talk to your own doctor or doctors look
at the data
factor in your unique medical history
your current medical condition
make your own decision in consultation
with your doctors but if democrats
if the media mob continue to panic
downplay the efficacy of
vaccines with mass mandates and
lockdowns
well the trust will be eroded even
further and perhaps even
shattered forever and by the way if
democrats are truly concerned about the
dangers of coven 19
maybe they should be addressing that
ongoing crisis at our southern border
because for the past six months we have
a record number of migrants
the biggest number now looks like it'll
be in 25 years from all over the world
they have been pouring into this country
illegally almost
all of them are completely unvaccinated
most if not all of them hardly any are
tested for covet 19. there's been a high
rate of
covet positivity when tested and yet as
we speak the biden administration
they're they're actually dispersing them
into towns and cities
and counties all over the country so to
recap according to democrats
in order to be a good citizen you must
listen to them even though their opinion
changes by the hour
you've got to mask up socially distance
take many precautionary measures
but when it comes to the southern border
oh culver 19 it's not a priority down
there
and those that are even being offered
vaccines foxnews.com had a report
if you be if you're entering the country
illegally about a third of them turn it
down
but they still let them in how does that
make any sense at all hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else